I got you
Welcome back everyone this is my full breakdown
and easter eggs video for the batman movie
hopefully you've had a chance to see the movie
once or twice by now there are so many things
that we have to talk about so if you're new to the
channel we are doing a giveaway for imax tickets
so you can go back and see it a billion more times
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
just post your favorite moment from the movie in
the comments careful for spoilers for the entire
movie we'll be talking about everything and matt
reeves has also clarified some of the easter eggs
and cameo scenes like the post credits scene
since the movie has come out so if you still
have a lot of questions about some of the big
twists like the joker of it all i do have a lot
of answers about that what i'll do is i'll start
at the beginning of the movie and go through scene
by scene talking about all the easter eggs wtf
moments i'll jump around a little bit but i will
try to go through the movie in a linear fashion
for the most part the actual opening scene is
of the riddler watching the mayor and his family
on halloween night getting ready to kill him and
start his grand plan to take out carmine falcone
and all the corrupt people in positions of power
who are working for him that included the mayor
gil coulson the district attorney pete savage the
gotham city police commissioner and bruce wayne
the last surviving member of the wayne family
he was going after thomas wayne but because
bruce was the last one in the family that
was left alive he went after bruce the whole
reason why he was after thomas wayne bruce wayne
is because he blames thomas wayne for creating
the circumstances that allowed all these corrupt
powerful people to continue prospering for the
past 20 years because thomas wayne created the
well-intentioned but flawed billion dollar gotham
city renewal fund that's why he writes renewal is
a lie riddler's real name is edward nashton which
is from the comics the whole reason he found out
falcone was behind all this is because he was a
forensic accountant working for the gotham city
renewal fund so that's how he got the ledgers and
just followed the money trail learning all these
secrets when he's actually killing the mayor it's
on halloween night this aspect of the plot normal
person being driven to become a villain going
around taking out even worse corrupt people in
a lot of other very specific scenes all inspired
by batman the long halloween story in the comics
in real life matt reeves college screenwriting
teacher was jeff loeb himself the person who wrote
long halloween there were also a lot of batman
hush easter eggs jeff loeb also wrote batman
hush the look and the vibe of this version of the
riddler is mostly inspired by the zodiac killer in
real life the way he used ciphers his mannerisms
his actual costume like the zodiac killer dressed
exactly like this the song that's playing over
the opening scene is ave maria later in the movie
riddler also starts singing it in arkham when he
and batman are going at it and he knows that his
bombs are about to collapse the barriers and
the big attack on the election is going down
the song was also playing inside the gotham
city orphanage when batman and gordon find
the riddler's clue about thomas wayne and going
after bruce wayne next riddler wanted vengeance
for the way thomas wayne all these other corrupt
powerful people he kills forgot about him and the
other children of the orphanage when they were
younger ave maria the song is actually a prayer
to the virgin mary that they sing in the catholic
faith it gets sung a lot by choirs so i think the
idea is that the riddler these are the little kids
were made to sing it as children and that's why in
present day he's using it as sort of his anthem
for vengeance also this version of the gotham
city orphanage is in the original wayne manor
if you wondered where bruce wayne's mansion was
in the movie thomas wayne before his death had
moved the family to the penthouse in the city
and donated the old mansion to the city to be used
as the orphanage in the dark knight trilogy batman
ends doing the exact same thing he uses his will
to turn wayne manor into an orphanage inside the
mayor's house ridler sees his son dressed up as a
ninja for halloween mock killing him i don't think
it's meant to be an overt league of assassins
easter egg but you could look at it that way the
riddler kills the mayor using the carpet-laying
tool because it's all part of his grand plan to
leave larger clues for batman that he wants him
to solve so that he'll eventually learn about his
final plan to attack the election having hit
his map of the city with a plan all drawn out
underneath a carpet in his apartment left for
batman to find the apartment that's right next
door to the iceberg lounge that's also a big comic
book reference the iceberg lounge is something
that the penguin creates later after he becomes
the penguin is this sort of posh club where
gotham's elite come where he hobnobs with them
and holds court in the movie penguin starts out
as falcone's second in command and is sort of like
a scarface inside the batman universe situation
matt reeves said we'll see him go full scarface
during the batman hbo spin-off series where he
starts to take over falcone's former territory
inside this version of the iceberg lounge they
also have a special club within the club for
the really special people called 44 below
as in 44 below zero below freezing also because
it's literally below the ground inside the mayor's
apartment you also see a bunch of framed newspaper
clippings of his big takedowns one of them is for
sal moroney's big drug bust that's the event that
falcone used to get all these powerful people in
the government and the police on his payroll a
long time ago as part of riddler's plan to unmask
the corruption metaphorically literally in gotham
he uses his website with the url ratalata.com
which loosely translates to rat with wings because
this whole plan is really about getting rid of
carmine falcone the source of the corruption
falcon was the rat who informed all these
powerful people how to take down salmoroni making
their careers and falcons have wings so falcone
was the rat with wings also the funny connection
to batman is that bats are like rats with wings
matt reeves designed this to be kind of like a
world's greatest detective batman movie in the
movie penguin literally calls batman the world's
greatest detective the real reason riddler kept
writing to batman wasn't because he learned his
secret identity and wanted to punish him because
he was going after bruce wayne too at least during
the events of the movie he has not yet learned
bratman is bruce wayne not yet i think he will
eventually though he'd been writing to batman
because he'd become a fan of his the past two
years he'd been following the news about all of
batman's takedowns in the news the movie takes
place at the end of batman year two that's why
at the beginning of the movie he says two years of
knights have turned him into a nocturnal creature
turned him into a bat metaphorically as he has
been literally turning himself into the batman
riddler felt like they had been on the same
mission we're the same we're trying to do the
same thing during their last conversation arkham
asylum riddler even explains that he felt like
batman and he were a team working together this
whole time the batman hush easter eggs sort of
culminate at the end of the movie during this
conversation in arkham 2 where batman thinks
for a second that riddler has learned a secret
identity because inside riddler's apartment
there were a bunch of newspaper clippings with
scrawlings across them saying who is the batman
so riddler was trying to find out who batman
was and during their conversation riddler keeps
repeating the name bruce wayne over and over in
this really creepy way so batman thinks that it's
all over and he's going to reveal his identity to
make himself famous but then they kind of have a
wtf funny moment where he takes it back and says
we almost had him we almost had bruce wayne batman
realizes that his secret is still safe and gets
really pissed at riddler and that's when ridler
starts to hate batman for calling him a crazy
person not reciprocating his offer of friendship
or partnership it's okay though riddler does
wind up making a friend at the end of the movie
but the other big batman hush easter egg is for
the reporter that falcone killed for thomas wayne
his name was elliot and during the riddler's
viral video for thomas wayne across the screen
he literally writes the word hush but matt
reeves actually clarified that the reporter
is not literally meant to be his version of the
hush character the opening narration of that first
batman scene is also right out of the comics is
also right out of the long halloween story line
in fact if you went to one of the special
preview screenings for the movie this past week
dc was giving away free special editions of
the long halloween in the theaters batman's
first takedown is the drophead dressed in the drop
head mask there's also an anti-drug advertisement
on the billboard here about the drops they were
the designer drug that salmaroni was originally
selling in the city then falcone ratted him out
took over his drug operation and installed all
of his people in positions of power but speaking
of drugs in the movie batman also injects himself
at the end during this big final fight with the
green fluid that seems kind of like the bane venom
serum gordon fires up the bat signal in the movie
they've been using it for a good long while but
because gordon is not commissioner and the rest
of the police basically hate batman he and gordon
have the bat signal at a secret location maybe
once gordon eventually becomes commissioner he'll
put the bat signal on top of police headquarters
like it is in the comics and in the other movies
his second big takedown is the gang dressed in
the skeleton makeup they seem like they might
be part of joker's game from the comics because
of the makeup that they're wearing but because
this version of the joker played by barry keoghan
in that cameo scene hasn't fully become the joker
yet he isn't using the joker name i don't think
there's literally meant to be a connection between
this gang and his character but this actor here
jayla sergo also played a version of tim drake
robin during titan season 3. that takes place in
a different universe so this is just a coincidence
in the context of the movie he's just meant to be
a regular kid who batman scares straight literally
like he's so terrified of batman now that he
won't commit any more crimes but the riddler's
first clue that he leaves for batman at the mayors
is an owl halloween card halloween because of the
long halloween the owl you can also take as one
of the many court of owls references in the movie
robert pattinson himself even said the court
of owls is probably going to be one of the main
villains in the sequel movies thomas and martha
were leaders of the court of owls in this timeline
i like that one oh that's a i was definitely kind
of thinking that the quarterback is probably going
to be in the sequel it definitely seems nice mommy
i'm literally just guessing i just keep saying it
good thing it's not in this film or is it or is
it the other court of owls easter eggs are in
the new backstory for thomas and martha wayne in
the history of their family the history of gotham
the riddler reveals in the video that martha wayne
came from the arkham family and the waynes and the
arkhams are the two founding families of gotham
city the court of owls is this group made up of
all the founding families of gotham secretly
controlling events in the city for hundreds
of years they might get into that more during the
batman arkham series because martha wayne's family
created arkham asylum so we're just teasing more
of this secret history of gotham that they'll
continue revealing through the rest of the stories
and riddler's first riddle is what does a liar do
when he's dead the answer is he lies still his
second riddle is actually for pete savage the
commissioner follow the maze till you find the rat
bring him into the light you'll find where i'm at
the answer is carmine falcone bring him into
the light literally under the street lamp
outside the iceberg lounge and he'll find where
ridler's apartment is even though this is a mad
scientist card you could think of the use of mad
specifically by matt reeves as a reference to mad
hatter the third riddle is actually a series
of three different riddles for gil coulson
the first one was it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied it's violence you may find
the answer is justice the second one is if you
are justice please do not lie what is the price
for your blind eye the answer is the price of
his bribes which were about 10 grand a month
the third one since your justice is so select
please tell us which vermin you're paid to protect
the answer was carmine falcone the next riddle
comes from his attempt to kill bruce wayne with
the bomb alfred opened the mail setting it off
riddler didn't know that he wouldn't do that he
was hoping the bruce wayne himself would open
it that's why in the package it said for his
eyes only the reason why the card for batman
was left in a fireproof envelope is because
he didn't know that they were the same person and
he wanted bruce wayne to die in the explosion but
the card to survive so that batman would find it
it just says see you in hell which was meant to
be a reference to batman visiting him in arkham
after he gets captured because the riddler knew
that eventually the police would capture him
and throw him in arkham the next riddle is his
confession at his apartment the lines he drew
all over the cart here are a map reference to
the floor map in the election his next riddle at
arkham is actually for the election attack itself
what's black and blue and dead all over the answer
is batman himself because he expects batman to die
trying to save bella royale and all the other
people there then even though it's not his riddle
the next riddle is actually joker's riddle riddle
me this the less of them you have the more one is
worth the answer is a friend just teasing joker
riddler team up in the next big project like matt
reeves said the next place they'll address this
will probably be during the arkham series on hbo
the final riddle is actually during that post
credits scene in the final message from the rats
alata website saying goodbye with a question mark
as if to say this isn't the end and the riddler's
deep breathing over the scene meant to show that
he recorded another video which we have not seen
yet but at the mayor's house his son finds his
body batman sort of sees himself in the little boy
because he also witnessed his parents murder and
crime alley later he saves the boy's life twice
once at the funeral during the gilcolson attack
and then again at the end of the movie at the
election i do not think the boy is meant to
be some future robin i think it's just batman
trying to metaphorically save himself like
he sees the boy as another version of him
they reveal his version of the bat cave at
least at this point in his timeline is inside
an abandoned subway terminal called the wayne
terminus literally built by his family long ago
we get a quick look at some of his gadgets
his gear all over the place we learned that
he uses special contact lenses which can record
video he also keeps a handwritten journal for
each night that he spends fighting crime as
batman and he calls his work becoming the
batman the gotham project like the batman
is literally bruce wayne's gotham project
i think the idea with these journals that they're
setting up for the future potentially for a big
payoff at the end of whatever matt ray's trilogy
is going to be eventually one of them will publish
his journals publicly like rorschach's journal
at the end of watchmen when alfred and batman
start arguing about wayne enterprises and all the
accountants in his family's legacy possibly going
away it's because at this point he does not care
about being bruce wayne 99 pecent of his time is
spent in full-on batman mode he hasn't developed
the billionaire playboy bruce wayne persona yet
and because he's spending so much of his wealth on
all of his batman gear and he's still technically
in charge of wayne enterprises neglecting
those regular business duties he's burning
through all of his assets takes an awful lot of
money to be batman gotta get that from somewhere
the reason why alfred is able to decode the
riddler ciphers is because he used to be a
member of british military intelligence before he
became thomas wayne's butler when they discover
the mayor's thumb drive and he goes back to
the iceberg lounge to question penguin they
introduced away kravis's selena kyle catwoman
for the first time she's very similar to batman
in that the selena kyle waitress persona is the
mask catwoman is her real personality her being
carmine falcone's secret daughter also a twist
right out of the long halloween story falcone also
later confesses to being the mystery person who
strangled her mother to death when she was a child
when batman catches her in the actor trying to
steal her friend's passport from the mayor's safe
that's also right out of the long halloween but in
the original story it was happening inside carmine
falcone's house at the mayor's funeral falcone
tells the story of how thomas wayne saved his life
when they were younger that's also right out of
the long halloween in the movie falcone used the
event to get closer to thomas wayne pretending
to be his friend and when the reporter tries
to out martha wayne's history of mental health
issues thomas wayne asked falcone to scare him
not knowing that he'd have him killed falcone had
planned to use the event to control thomas wayne
but when he told him that he was going to confess
everything to the police falcone had joe chill
kill them in crime alley they never actually show
the crime alley scene because we've seen it so
many times it's like uncle ben dying in spider-man
movies like how many times do you need to watch
uncle ben die then they reveal the new batmobile
during the big chase scene with the penguin it's
a souped-up muscle car with a jet engine the idea
is that over time all of his gear all of his tech
the batmobile will evolve all of his stuff right
now is just meant to feel very homemade like a
billionaire in his butler could actually spend a
bunch of money and build stuff like this in their
garage just the two of them then when the riddler
allows himself to be captured after he kills
falcone that's because he's already set everything
in motion for the election attack and feels like
his quest is complete like he did everything he
set out to do when they actually do arrest the
riddler he has two different ids inside his wallet
one is for edward nashton which is his actual
name but the other id reads patrick parker that's
another alias the riddler used in the comics
i already explained all these batman hush easter
eggs during their final argument his final riddle
here before batman goes to try and stop the attack
but during the attack all these people are meant
to be riddler's followers who are watching his
videos this whole time other conspiracy theorists
have been drinking the kool-aid and just gotten
hocked up and are ready to kill a whole bunch
of people i've already explained that easter egg
for the venom serum here but he also reveals that
his batman symbol on his chest doubles as a
tactical knife he can pull it out of his chest and
use it as a tool as a weapon like a batarang and
as he narrates over the ending things are going to
get worse before they get better because gotham is
still flooded and there's this crime element parts
of the city the police can't get to they show the
penguin in the iceberg lounge just looking out
over everything getting ready to make a huge power
play taking over carmine falcone's former empire
that'll all play out during the batman
hbo episodes for the penguin series
but then back in arkham asylum they have their
infamous joker cameo scene with barry keohan's
version of the character confirmed by matt reeves
as the new version of the joker in this universe
he says what is it they say one day
you're on top the next year a clown
big joker reference then he says let me tell you
there are worse things than being in trails off
he was about to say there are worse things than
being a clown and don't be sad you did so well
you know gotham loves a comeback story like the
riddler will come back as full comic book riddler
and riddle me this riddler's trademark catch
phrase the less of them you have the more one is
worth like i said just teasing joker riddler team
up in the future mostly on the hbo arkham series
reeves said that he doesn't have a plan for joker
right now in the movies but he actually does plan
to bring him back during the arkham hbo series
there was a deleted scene with the joker and it
took place earlier when batman is interrogating
riddler before the final election attack
when he came to arkham he was actually going to
walk by the joker's cell and joker was going to
try and provoke him saying it looks like it's our
anniversary and it was meant to show that joker
and batman had history before joker became joker
like he hasn't taken the joker name yet he did
something terrible enough to get himself thrown in
arkham by batman they might wind up releasing that
deleted scene online sometime in the next couple
of months at the end of the movie catwoman says
she's going to bludhaven to lay low because it's
too crazy in gotham right now bloodhaven is where
dick grayson is from in the comics they could
always introduce a version of dick grayson in
the future but then i already explained that post
credit scene with the rata elata website message
just a teaser for him broadcasting another video
like he recorded a secret video that we have not
watched yet it's an actual website that you can
visit in real life so maybe that's where they'll
post that deleted scene of the joker but if you
spotted any other huge easter eggs in the movie
that i didn't mention in the video write them
below in the comments i will do another joker
video later this weekend after people have a
chance to see the movie click here for my video
on the batman ending the joker scene the post
credits scene and click here for my full review of
the movie thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!